[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei die richtigen
fragen noch einmal an diese mittlerweile
so späten sonntagabend kurz vor viertel
vor elf melden wir uns noch einmal mit
einer sondersendung die richtigen fragen
wir gehen noch nicht schlafen und sie
sollten das auch nicht tun denn wir
zeigen ihnen ein wichtiges ein
spektakuläres ein welt exklusives
interview dass meinem kollegen bild vize
paul ronzheimer da im fern- kabul in
afghanistan gelungen ist es ist ein
gespräch mit ihm hier mit dem gesicht
und der stimme der taliban mit dem
taliban sprecher mudschahid er hat sich
heute bild live gestellt dort in kabul
und wir wollen ihnen dieses interview
jetzt in ganzer länge zeigen immer
wieder analysiert und eingeordnet
natürlich von paul ronzheimer selbst und
von bild chef julian reichelt euch
beiden schönen guten abend ganz kurz
bevor wir reinschauen julian warum ist
dieses interview für uns für die ganze
welt wichtig
dieses interview zeigt das ja
atemberaubende und wirklich unfassbare
dilemma in dem die westliche welt sich
jetzt befindet 20 jahre haben wir leben
aus westlichen ländern soldaten aus
westlichen ländern eingesetzt um diese
menschen zu bekämpfen mit denen paul
jetzt sprechen konnte und die jetzt zum
beispiel bewerten sprechen
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel großzügig
zum gespräch nach kabul eingeladen haben
da hat sich tatsächlich innerhalb von
wenigen tagen die weltlage komplett
geändert unser blick auf die taliban hat
sich da komplett ändern müssen aus
feinden sind jetzt verhandlungspartner
geworden innerhalb von tagen und das ist
das was wir in diesem interview auch
wirklich beeindruckende weise sehen
werden paul bei dir ist es mittlerweile
tief tief tief in der nacht wie bist du
an dieses interview gekommen wie kam es
dazu
wir haben tagelang wochenlang versucht
an diesem land bekommen in den letzten
tagen war das kaum möglich über ein
afghanischen kontakt wir haben immer
wieder hin und her geschrieben und er
war mit den regierungskonsultationen
beschäftigt es steht ja immer noch keine
regierung hier und es hieß immer nein
überhaupt keine zeit wir sind nicht da
und dann heute ganz plötzlich am morgen
kam der anruf ja ecken kommen und dann
war so viel verkehr in kabul dass wir
nicht das aufzunehmen konnten sondern
gerannt sind die straßen hoch in das
ministerium zum sprecher der taliban
weil manchmal ist kabuse voll dass man
für einen kurzen weg ein zwei stunden
braucht und wir sind gerannt und haben
das interview bekommen jetzt wollen wir
dieses interview gemeinsam anschauen und
ich habe es gerade schon gesagt
zwischendurch immer wieder einordnen
analysieren die worte des
taliban-sprechers lassen wir natürlich
nicht einfach so stehen sondern wollen
tatsächlich nahm im miteinander
diskutieren was diese worte bedeuten und
jetzt schauen wir in den ersten teil
deines interviews paul gemeinsam rein
helmut zurzeit finden in doha aber auch
von hier aus viele gespräche mit der
deutschen regierung statt können sie und
sagen um welche art von gesprächen es
sich handelt und was bisher vereinbart
wurde
soweit ich weiß haben wir einen
sonderbeauftragten für die europäischen
länder in unserem politischen büro in
doha es handelt sich um herrn malawi
abdullah quasi er ist in kontakt mit
vielen ländern und vor allem mit
deutschland der vertreter deutschlands
war in unserem politischen büro in doha
wir haben uns mehrmals mit ihm getroffen
und sind immer noch in kontakt der
kontakt verläuft auch gut dass bei
unseren treffen ging es um die deutsche
präsenz in afghanistan in den letzten 20
jahren und darum dass der tumult und die
hysterie in unserem land auch
deutschland betroffen hat in afghanistan
befanden sich ja auch deutsche truppen
aber jetzt versuchen wir den dingen eine
positive wendung zu geben und ein neues
kapitel aufzuschlagen indem wir einen
richtigen austausch und gute
diplomatische beziehungen pflegen
außerdem wären wir sehr froh wenn
deutschland uns und die menschen in
unserem land unterstützen würde denn
historisch gesehen hatten wir starke und
gute diplomatische und wirtschaftliche
beziehungen zu deutschland es gibt in
kabul außerdem noch ein paar gebäude die
von der deutschen regierung errichtet
wurden wir möchten die freundschaftliche
atmosphäre wieder beleben die zwischen
afghanen und deutschen bestand die
nächste regierung wird auf einer
freundschaftlichen beziehungen zu
deutschland beruhigt
wir hören von so vielen deutschen orts
treffen die sich noch in afghanistan
aufhalten und aus angst das land
verlassen möchten wie können sie
afghanistan verlassen und was sagen sie
den menschen die sich jetzt verstecken
erstens möchten wir dass niemand angst
vor afghanistan und den afghanen hat wir
haben nicht nur viele deutsche
diplomaten in afghanistan auch viele
deutsche afghanen leben in unserem land
sie sollten keine angst haben denn wir
können ihnen versichern dass nichts und
niemand sie bedrohen kann
für diejenigen die das land freiwillig
verlassen möchten gibt es kein problem
aber zuerst sollte das außenministerium
seine arbeit aufnehmen
wenn menschen das land verlassen wollen
sollte dass auf legale weise geschehen
sie sollten einen pass und ein visum
besitzen
wir haben mit niemandem ein problem weil
jedes individuen frei entscheiden kann
alle menschen haben das recht dort zu
leben wo sie es wollen
abgesehen davon müssen wir warten bis
der flughafen seinen betrieb wieder
aufnimmt dann kann jeder das land auf
legale weise verlassen und sie werden
keine probleme haben
können also auch die afghanen die mit
der deutschen regierung
zusammengearbeitet haben das land
verlassen garantieren
wir haben den afghanen die für
deutschland oder ein anderes land
gearbeitet haben keine probleme bereitet
und werden es auch nicht tun
wir werden dafür sorgen dass sie sicher
leben können sie werden nicht belangt
werden und ihr leben ist nicht in gefahr
denn es war eine zeit des kämpfens die
nun beendet ist wir haben sogar eine
amnestie für all die soldaten und
generäle verkündet die hunderte und
tausende von taliban und zivilisten
getötet haben
jetzt leben sie mit uns in kabul und den
provinzen und es gibt keine probleme und
keinen grund sie zu bedrohen
auch für die afghanen die mit
deutschland zusammen gearbeitet haben
wird es keine probleme geben wenn sie
freiwillig das land verlassen wollen
werden sie den legalen weg einschlagen
müssen
gleichzeitig werden wir wissen dass die
afghanen die afghanistan verlassen nicht
unter ungewissen bedingungen leben sowie
die afghanen die im ausland leben und
sich in einem juristischen
schwebezustand
die humanitäre situation in ihrem land
es problematisch sie bitten deutschland
um finanzielle unterstützung wie hoch
sollte diese unterstützung ausfallen
erstens möchten wir dass eine gute
beziehung zu deutschland entsteht das
islamische emirat wird die gewünschte
regierung der afghanen sein und wir
möchten dass die deutsche regierung die
bestmöglichen diplomatischen beziehungen
zu unserer neuen regierung unterhält
zweitens möchten wir dass deutschland
uns im humanitären bereich unterstützt
und hilft so weit die deutsche regierung
dies
außerdem benötigen wir hilfe im
gesundheitswesen im bildungsbereich und
bei der infrastruktur
wir glauben dass uns die deutsche
regierung wirklich helfen kann
zudem könnte die deutsche regierung
ihrer unternehmerinnen und unternehmer
ermutigen zu uns zu kommen und in unser
land zu investieren
wir werden den weg dafür ebnen
wir werden den weg dafür ebnen und ihre
sicherheit gewährleisten kurz gesagt
kann uns die deutsche regierung in
verschiedenen bereichen helfen damit
sich unser land weiterentwickelt und der
wohlstand wächst
deutschland spielt dabei also eine
wichtige rolle darauf zählen wir und
deutschland sollte sich keine sorgen
gab es von ihrer seite aus bereits
versuche angela merkel oder heiko maas
zu kontaktieren wir haben mit den
vertretern deutschlands gesprochen und
ihr sonderbeauftragter kam auch zu
unserem politischen büro in doha ich bin
mir sicher dass sie frau merkel unsere
botschaften übermittelt haben ich
persönlich habe es aber nicht versuchen
würden sie die deutsche bundeskanzlerin
hier in afghanistan willkommen heißen
ja natürlich wir wollen eine voll und
ganz sichere umgebung hier in
afghanistan das von allen ländern der
welt akzeptiert wird und dann das die
staats und regierungschefs glauben sie
sollen uns besuchen und angela merkel
würde besonders herzlich aufgenommen
werden wir würden uns wirklich sehr über
sie freuen
der taliban sprecher mudschahid der die
bundeskanzlerin nach kabul einlädt
darüber müssen und wollen wir sprechen
mit bild chef julian reichelt und bild
vize power einsame der wie sie es gerade
gesehen haben dieses interview geführt
hat mit dem taliban-sprecher dem gesicht
und der stimme der taliban paulas er das
gesagt hat diese herzliche einladung
ausgesprochen hat alles an die kanzlerin
als wärst du das gefühl das meint der
jetzt genauso das meint er so herzlich
so ernst
so richtig was ich hier glauben soll was
ich denken soll und fühlen soll manchmal
dann ist es so ein absurdistan geworden
hier auch was dieser mann dieser
taliban-sprecher dort in dem interview
gesagt hat denn noch einmal das waren
diejenigen gegen die wir 20 jahre
gekämpft haben die hier auf der straße
wahrscheinlich sofort versucht hätten
hier in kabul mich zu lynchen nicht zu
erschießen und jetzt sitzt man da auf
dem sofa neben ihm und er erzählt dass
die kanzlerin jetzt zu besuch kommen
will also für mich war das eine reale
begegnung und auch diese aussagen ich
kann das nicht so richtig fassen und ich
weiß auch nicht ob ich es nicht glauben
soll das wird sicherlich die nächsten
tage die nächsten wochen zeigen aber
ganz sicher aus dem hintergrund der
taliban macht das alles sinn sie wollen
das geld aus dem westen und natürlich
wäre das für sie propaganda welt das
allergrößte wenn die taliban die
kanzlerin ausgerechnet jetzt hier zu
besuch käme also julian der ist so lange
freundlich solange der unser geld will
und bekommt also das heißt er meint dass
erstmal so herzlich weil der wille eine
ganze menge von uns
ja natürlich ist es genau das aber was
hier bemerkenswert ist er ist das
vollkommen neue und gewandelte auftreten
der taliban da muss man sich fragen was
wollen sie damit erreichen die taliban
sind kommunikations mäßig derzeit
offenbar besser beraten als so manche
wahlkampf in deutschland sie haben
vollkommen neuen sound gefunden sie sind
sanft sie sprechen die sprache des der
versöhnung des vergebens sie wissen dass
das
der ton ist der erste im westen ankommt
aber vor allem auch der ton ist der im
westen ja so dringend gebraucht wird
vergessen wir nicht das was wir in den
letzten wochen erlebt haben dass das
größte außen und
verteidigungspolitischen die waage der
letzten jahrzehnte
beantwortet von unserer bundeskanzlerin
verantwortet vom us-präsidenten
verantwortet von all den staats- und
regierungschef westlicher länder die
sich dort engagiert haben die brauchen
ja jetzt etwas und das wissen die
taliban weil sie offenbar
kommunikativ fabelhaft beratenden sind
und sich in den letzten zwei jahrzehnten
die sie gekämpft haben auch in ihrer
sprache und in ihrer fähigkeit politik
zu machen extrem weiterentwickelt haben
und ich würde sagen zu der
entscheidenden frage was können wir den
glauben natürlich erst mal gar nix aber
was wir ihn durchaus glauben könnt ist
dass sie für sich das beste rausholen
wollen und sie sehen natürlich dass die
welt sich gewandelt hat das selbst für
regime wie ein mögliches taliban-regime
sehr viel rauszuholen ist und wenn ich
die sprache des taliban-sprechers höhere
erinnert mich das sehr eine islamische
republik iran ebenfalls ein grauenvoller
mullah staat in dem die scharia geht der
ist aber geschafft hat durch ein
atomprogramm indem man druck gemacht hat
auf den westen für sich die bestmögliche
position rauszuholen mit dem deutschen
außenminister im amerikanischen
zumindest am verhandlungstisch sitzt ich
glaube da haben sich die taliban eine
gesamt geschaut und genau das werden sie
jetzt auch versuchen ich prognostiziere
sie werden erfolg haben jetzt landet ihr
in diesen sekunden in diesen minuten via
bild live diese einladung im kanzleramt
auf dem tisch der kanzlerin sollte sie
julian diese einladung annehmen
nein die sollte sie natürlich unter gar
keinen umständen an dem wobei die
kanzlerin auch schon gegen alle neben
anderen menschen gestanden hat die blut
an den händen haben gerade neulich
wladimir putin der hier in berlin
menschen umbringt ist also wäre nicht
das erste mal dass sie neben männern mit
zweifelhaftem weltbild und gruppen
wertesystem sitzen würde aber auf jeden
fall wird angela merkel auf dieses
angebot eigentlich in dem sie und sie
ist man sieht schon darauf eingegangen
sie hat ja als ich für die verhandlung
mit den taliban ausgesprochen sie wird
das nicht auf ihrem level machen wird
sie nicht sollte sie nicht vermutlich
bleibt kaum noch genug zeit dazu habe
sie würde es ohnehin nicht tun aber
diese verhandlungen werden ja bereits
geführt und ich glaube dass wir
innerhalb relativ kurzer zeit eine
konferenz erleben werden die große
konferenz armin laschet hat sie
vorgeschlagen
der vorschlag kommt aber auch aus
anderen ländern eine konferenz auf
außenministerebene erleben war bei denen
die taliban anwesend sind und
außenminister aus aller welt und wenn
die chinesen und die russen erstmals
ihre außenminister schicken weil diese
das ganze ganz anders betrachten würde
es mich nicht wundern wenn heiko maas
eine seiner letzten reise
noch zu den taliban machen kann pauli
jetzt hast du ja auch eine ja sozusagen
amnestie für all diejenigen angesprochen
die deutschland die die westlichen
truppen die die bundeswehr die
bundesregierung dort in afghanistan so
tatkräftig unterstützt haben in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten den vergangenen
20 jahren und da gab es dann sehr
freundliche worte von den taliban
sprecher mudschahid und er hat ihnen
garantiert dass es keine probleme geben
werde für sie jetzt ist es ja nicht so
wichtig vielleicht wie wir das
beurteilen aber du bist in ständigem
kontakt ja mit diesen sogenannten
ortskräfte mit vielen die noch da
bleiben mussten weil sie es nicht
rechtzeitig aus geschafft haben also was
geht denen durch den kopf wenn sie diese
zusicherung hören fühlen die sich dabei
etwas erleichtert oder ja glauben die
das überhaupt nicht und leben in
schreckliche angst
nein kann die menschen die hier in kabul
in vielzahl sich versteckten tausende
menschen musst du dir vorstellen den
glauben davon kein wort ich habe in den
vergangenen tagen viele getroffen und es
ist ja schon mehrfach vorgekommen dass
der sprecher hier gesagt hat es gibt
eine amnestie und die menschen haben mir
gesagt in ihren verstecken selbst wenn
er das so meint selbst wenn er sagt okay
wir machen das jetzt so wer sagt mir
denn dass alle taliban hier auf den
straßen das so sehen wer sagt mir dann
dass es nicht machtkämpfe gibt wie man
mit den orts kräften umgeht und wir
hören aus dem taliban umfeld dass es die
bereits gibt natürlich es gibt
diejenigen die ein besonders radikales
vorgehen wollen und andere die sagen wir
müssen mit dem westen verhandeln
deswegen darf da nichts passieren
deswegen darf es keine rache geben aber
in afghanistan muss man sich das so
vorstellen man stelle sich vor der
cousin xy wurde getötet von einer von
von der us-armee und dieser cousin der
andere bezichtigt jetzt denjenigen ihn
verraten zu haben also da gibt es ganz
ganz viele offene rechnungen und
vielleicht ein aktuelles beispiel kai
ich kenne ja ein übersetzer der mit
internationalen solisten unterwegs war
der wurde dann gesehen von den taliban
hier an verschiedenen checkpoints und
die haben gesagt moment mal du hast doch
in der vergangenheit auch mit den
amerikanern gearbeitet und jetzt mit
journalisten das geht aber nicht pass
lieber auf hör auf zu arbeiten also das
was gesagt wird und dass das was dann
wirklich passiert da ist noch ein
gewaltiger unterschied sagt mir noch 1
paul wo wir dich in dem interview in dem
ersten teil gesehen haben mit dem
taliban sprecher mudschahid wie war das
atmosphäre auch drum herum ist das da
wird da auch mal gescherzt oder ist es
total distanziert läuft das
professionell ab beschreibt uns ein
bisschen wie das drumherum abgeben
ja es war so dass der anruf sehr spontan
kam dass der mann immer unterwegs ist
zwischen den verschiedenen
verhandlungsteilen hier es gibt im
serena-hotel das bekannteste hotel der
stadt dort sind viele pakistanische
offizielle und teile der anführer der
taliban wo dann auch der sprecher oft
unterwegs waren es geht dann hin und her
vom palast und in diese hotels in diese
verhandlungsgruppen insgesamt muss man
sagen war das gespräch sehr entspannt
das war ein büro ein ehemaliges
ministerbüro ministry for culture &
information also für kultur und
information wo vorher die afghanische
regierung war und das haben jetzt die
taliban besetzt und dahinter gab es
viele afghanische bücher also noch aus
dem alten büro und ohnehin hat man das
gefühl dass sie eben ausstrahlen wollen
wir sind anders wir sind nicht mehr so
wie euch uns vorstellt das hat nichts
mehr mit dem zu tun wer wir sind aber
noch einmal das wird sich erst zeigen
müssen in den nächsten wochen und leid
du hast ihn kritisch befragt du hast sie
ihn auch wie wir jetzt im zweiten
interview teil sehen können ganz
explizit vor allen dingen auf die rolle
der frauen künftig im taliban
afghanistan gesprochen
gestern wurde bei einem protest in kabul
brutal gegen frauen vorgegangen dürfen
frauen hier protestieren und was wird
ihre rolle sein dürfen sie arbeiten und
was es mit schulen und universitäten wie
werden die bestimmung aus
wir wollen eine islamische regierung und
eine islamische regierung hat ihre
eigenen regulierungen und vorschriften
die auf der scharia beruhen im islam
haben frauen ihre besonderen rechte die
rechte die ihnen der islam und die
scharia zu sprechen unterstützen wir
voll und ganz wir werden ihnen definitiv
ihre islamischen rechte zugestehen und
die frauen werden auch in verschiedenen
bereichen der regierung arbeiten zudem
arbeiten aktuell frauen im
gesundheitswesen und im bildungssektor
frauen dürfen gerne in diesen bereichen
arbeiten sobald die neue regierung
bekannt gegeben ist wird es auch
besondere anweisungen für sie geben der
wesentliche grund warum im moment keine
frauen in anderen bereichen arbeiten
besteht darin dass sie sich sowohl
physisch als auch mental sicher fühlen
sollen und auf dem weg zur arbeit nicht
ständig problemen begegnen in den ersten
tagen nach unserer ankunft in kabul gab
es leider ein paar frauen die physisch
und mental misshandelt wurden sie
standen auch einigen gesellschaftlichen
problemen gegenüber um all diese
probleme zu lösen warten wir noch auf
die neue regierung und arbeiten an neuen
und positiven veränderungen
was den protest betrifft muss ich ihnen
sagen dass die betroffenen frauen den
präsidentenpalast betreten wollten das
problem lautete dass dort kein
offizieller vertreter unserer seite
anwesend war wir sagten ihnen das aber
sie bestanden darauf sich gewaltsam
zutritt zu verschaffen und die
sicherheitskräfte gingen gegen sie vor
wir riefen unsere sondereinsatzkräfte um
die lage unter kontrolle zu bringen die
regierung wurde noch nicht vorgestellt
insofern ist jetzt nicht der richtige
zeitpunkt für proteste und
demonstrationen
diese frauen sollten geduld haben und
die neue regierung abwarten
aber warum wollen sie gestern
angegriffen
sie wurden nicht angegriffen zuerst
hatten sie versucht den
präsidentenpalast zu betreten an den
checkpoints sagten sie sie wollten ihn
betreten und im inneren des palastes
protestieren da sich niemand im palast
aufhielt sollten die sicherheitskräfte
an den checkpoints sie am betreten des
palastes hindern was geschehen ist war
nicht gut vertreter des
nachrichtendienstes trafen rechtzeitig
ein drängten die sicherheitsleute zurück
die gegen die frauen vorgänger
verhaftete personen wurden wieder
freigelassen
independence ich habe neulich am
unabhängigkeitstag in waldeck
teilgenommen und die menschen feierten
ihren sieg gegen die westlichen truppen
sie sagten von nun ein herrscher im land
die scharia was bedeutet dass herrscht
nun die scharia was sind ihre
wichtigsten regeln
die menschen in afghanistan sind muslime
die scharia ist das gesetz der regierung
deswegen haben die menschen dies betont
die afghanen haben 40 jahre lang dafür
gekämpft und der krieg der letzten
beiden jahrzehnte hatte unter anderem
zwei ziele erstens die präsenz der
internationalen streitkräfte zu beenden
zweitens die scharia in afghanistan
umzusetzen
die scharia ist das gesetz mit dem der
islam bestimmte regeln für einzelne
personen den staat und die gesellschaft
festlegt
wenn westliche länder flüchtlinge zurück
schicken würden weil sie ein verbrechen
begangen haben zb in deutschland werden
sie dank zukünftig entsprechend der
scharia bestraft in der future
in der tat ihr fall wird geprüft werden
und wenn sie mit ihrem verbrechen gegen
islamisches recht verstoßen haben und
wir sie bestrafen sollen werden kommen
sie vor gericht oder
sie werden bei einem geringfügigen
vergehen abgeschoben und die abschiebung
selber ist die strafe wenn sie ein
verbrechen begangen haben und der kläger
das gericht bittet sich der sache
anzunehmen werden sie natürlich
angeklagt
juliana kann das gesicht der taliban
teilweise noch so freundliche worte
sagen oder noch so freundlich
aussehenden teilen dieses interviews die
freundlichkeit hört eben da auf wo die
fratze der scharia beginnt ein
faszinierendes gespräch was man auf
jeden fall einmal sagen muss die taliban
sprechen im klang im sound der gewinner
sie sind selbstbewusst die sind selbst
sicher sie wissen der westen diese
militärische übermacht ist geschlagen
worden ist vertrieben worden nach 20
jahren herz ist im kampf nach 20 jahren
brutalsten krieg sie können für sich in
anspruch nehmen wir haben die nato
beschlag und genau mit diesem
selbstbewusstsein dieser souveränität
treten sie auf sie treten ganz klar auf
mit der botschaft wir haben ja ergeben
grund gelassen zu sein denn wir haben
nichts zu befürchten
nicht einmal von der nato interessanter
punkt wie der sprecher der taliban
selbst kritik geäußert hat aber dass man
mit einer demonstration mit frauen
vielleicht zu hart angegangen seien
undenkbar bis vor kurzem da merkt man
die kombination aus einerseits
siegesgewissheit
triumphalismus aber auf der anderen
seite eben auch sehr kluger pr-beratung
dann kommt es wie du gesagt hast zur
scharia die scharia das recht des islams
dass die taliban jetzt in afghanistan
einführen wollen und auch ganz sicher
einführen werden da sprechen sie von den
rechten der frauen die die frauen in der
stadt genießen nun ja rechte der frauen
in der serie sind nichts was wir bei uns
als rechte bezeichnet sondern als
massive einschränkung frauen wenn man
auch mal kurz julian das können wir noch
mal ganz kurz zitieren ich habe mir das
mal aufgeschrieben den satz dort von
herrn mutter hielt er sagt im islam
haben frauen ihre besonderen rechte die
rechte die ihnen der islam und die
scharia zu
sprechen und die unterstützen wir voll
und ganz voll und ganz ganz konkretes
beispiel wir frauen haben in der serie
das echt von männern und ihren gierigen
blicken geschützt zu sein deswegen
gehören sie unter die burka das ist ein
recht der frau das ist keine
einschränkung lass ich dich agiert das
ist ein recht der frau hin dass sich das
tier deswegen ja das stimmt die taliban
werden die rechte der scharia für frauen
umsätzen nur hat das nichts mit rechten
zu tun sondern das sind grausamste
einschränkung letzter punkt weil es ja
auch um straftäter ging und auch da ging
es um frauen
die straftäter der straftatbestand
vergewaltigung es geht ja in deutschland
immer wieder darum sollen wir
vergewaltiger nach afghanistan
abschieben ja natürlich sollten wir das
warum bei vergewaltiger nach der scharia
auf gar nichts in afghanistan gar nicht
zu befürchten haben die verweilt für die
vergewaltigung wird in afghanistan
nämlich nicht der mann bestraft sondern
die frau und zwar für ihr buch und
allerletzter punkte die scharia ist
nichts und das muss man einmal klar
sagen was die taliban jetzt mit
waffengewalt afghanistan aufzwingen die
afghanen leben in der überwältigenden
masse auf 20 jahren nach den gesetzen
der scharia ist es tatsächlich ein
zutiefst islamisches islamistisches land
was nach der stadt er lebt lebt und wie
sehr die afghanische bevölkerung die
scharia verinnerlicht hat man hier hängt
und gar nicht von ihr befreit werden
will erkennt man ja daran dass sie sehr
oft mitbringen nach deutschland wenn sie
zu uns kommen als flüchtlinge dann
lassen sie vieles zurück aber die stadt
hier zieht oft mit was dann bei uns oft
zu grauenvollen straftaten führt wie
erlebst du paul diese momente du sitzt
diesem taliban sprecher mudschahid
gegenüber er formuliert mal ganz locker
lässig entspannt welche rechte in
anführungsstrichen frauen in seinem land
haben und wie selbstverständlich das
natürlich ist die scharia mit ganzer
kraft und ganze grausamkeit
durchzusetzen
ich habe in dem moment an die frauen
gedacht die hier in den vergangenen
tagen protestiert haben oder auch an
diejenigen die sich versteckt halten und
dann diejenigen die angst haben vor
ihrer zukunft denn mehr oder weniger
während er das verkündet hat haben die
taliban regeln verkündet zum beispiel
für universitäten da ist jetzt davon die
rede dass es zwei eingänge gibt also
männer und frauen nicht mehr durch den
gleichen eingang gehen dürfen dann wurde
über schulen und universitäten
gesprochen auch da gibt es große sorgen
dass es am ende eben keine möglichkeit
mehr gibt für die bildung für frauen und
ich bekomme ganz ganz viele nachrichten
kai dadurch dass viele menschen wissen
dass ich hier bin von leuten aus der
stadt aus kabul die mir schreiben ich
kann hier als frau nicht mehr leben ich
will hier nicht leben ich habe riesige
angst das ist die realität und ich
glaube wie julian schon richtig sagt die
taliban verstehen wie sie hier pr machen
die frage wird sein was sind dann am
ende die gesetze die sie umsetzen und
das werden wir wahrscheinlich erst
erkennen wenn diese neue regierung
gebildet ist da sagt der sprecher auch
da muss man jetzt abwarten und schauen
aber dann wird hier die wahrheit auf den
tisch kommen wie frittierte in den tagen
julian wenn wir diese bilder sehen von
diesen wie du ja auch gesagt hast du
selbstbewussten taliban wie geordnet das
alles erscheint also die haben jetzt
eigentlich ja ein völliges tohuwabohu in
kabul und in afghanistan nach so vielen
jahrzehnten sind die plötzlich an der
macht eigentlich wir kennen das ja auch
viel geringerem level hier aus
deutschland wenn wir hier mal ein
regierungswechsel haben wie lange das
dauert bis man dann anfängt zu arbeiten
bis man sich geordnet hat und der
wechsel da in kabul der ist ja ist eine
größere veränderung tatsächlich und die
machen einen total geordneten eindruck
da sitzt mit paul der sprecher und sagt
ganz ganz in ruhe was die nächsten
schritte was die nächsten ziele sind das
erscheint mir völlig befremdlich wie
erklärst du dass
die taliban haben ein steinzeitliches
barbarisches weltbild und
auch immer wieder das werden sie noch
viel deutlicher zeigen in den jahren die
jetzt kommen werden ein steinzeitliches
barbarisches auftreten und vorging aber
sie sind nicht von menschen aus der
steinzeit und von barbaren beraten ganz
im gegenteil der pakistanische
geheimdienst hat seinen chef einfliegen
lassen faszinieren das foto lief da
gestern der pakistanische geheimdienst
in der lobby des tus jena wird eine
tasse tee in der hand im lockeren
weiteren gespräch mit vertretern der
taliban china und russland sind massiv
präsent vor ort die taliban haben
inzwischen hoch professionelle berater
die alle ihre eigenen interessen haben
aber die alle erst mal das interesse
haben dass die taliban erfolg haben und
dann sozusagen
erfolgreich als marionette eingesetzt
werden könnte wir wissen ja alle die
taliban werden keine geopolitischen
ansprüche stellen die taliban
werden nicht mit deutschland bilaterale
verhandlungen ziehen wohl die taliban
waren oder jedes regime in der region
war immer marionette für irgendwie das
letzte afghanische regime die letzte
afghanische regierung zutiefst korrupt
wie sie war war die marionette der
amerikaner das muss man so ganz klar
sagen und des westens und die taliban
sind jetzt die marionette wieder der
pakistan esther russen und die chinesen
und die tun im moment alles dafür von
fabis logistische unterstützung
organisation geld cash im kocher was man
sich nur vorstellen kann damit die
taliban dann ordentliche auftritt
hinlegen und das ist ein paar heute
erlebt das kriegen sie ganz gut hinten
wir wollen die beiden bild chef julian
reichelt und bild vize paul ronzheimer
jetzt gleich in den dritten teil dieses
beeindruckenden interviews reinschauen
und darin paul hast du auch an diesem
tag an dem wir hier in berlin über einen
fall berichten eines afghanen der brutal
auf eine frau eingestochen hat in berlin
wilmersdorf nur deshalb weil er diese
frau auf der straße hat arbeiten sehen
an diesem tag reden wir auch über die
abschiebung von straftätern zurück in
deren heimat nach afghanistan und
daraufhin hast du den taliban sprecher
mudschahid in deinem interview
angesprochen
zurück bei den richtigen fragen hier
eine dreiviertel stunde vor mitternacht
am sonntagabend mit dem ganz besonderen
ja spektakulären weil so exklusiven
interview von unserem kollegen bild vize
paul ronzheimer mit ihm nämlich mit dem
gesicht und der stimme der taliban den
taliban sprecher mudschahid dieses
interview paul hast du heute in kabul
führen können sagt uns noch einmal wie
kam das dazu
kann tagelang heiligt eine woche schon
versucht an den rand zu kommen erst der
mann der welt bekannt geworden ist er
ist das gesicht der taliban bevor sie
hier an die macht kamen kannten ihn
journalisten daher haben wir nie gesehen
er stand mit einzelnen den kontakt und
plötzlich wieder aufgetaucht wie so
viele hier in kabul und hat
pressekonferenzen gegeben normalerweise
ist es schwer ein so langes
einzelgespräche zu bekommen aber hier
mit unseren afghanischen kontakten haben
wir es dann geschafft und das ging dann
heute morgen ganz schnell wir mussten
dorthin rennen war zu viel verkehr ins
ministerium rhein ein ehemaliges
ministerium der afghanischen regierung
und da saßen wir dort schnell in seinem
büro und es ging los und wir hatten 45
minuten konnten mit ihm über alles
sprechen wie unwohl wie unsicher hast du
dich in dem moment in seinem büro in
diesen momenten gefühlt
unwohl kann ich nicht sagen weil ich
mich auf meinen job konzentriert habe
nämlich fragen zu stellen und man
gewöhnt sich hier in kabul daran
mittlerweile dass die taliban regieren
man muss das
beobachten man muss ihnen kritische
fragen stellen aber er ist jetzt nicht
derjenige der am unsympathischen bislang
war von den taliban die ich getroffen
habe vor ein paar tagen war ich bei dem
sogenannten unabhängigkeitstag also dort
wurde ich noch ein bisschen feindlicher
angeschaut als in diesem taliban büro ja
das kann man wohl sagen die blicke haben
wir ja hier live gesehen bei bild live
wurdest angeguckt wie ein mensch aus
einer anderen welt und ich habe in dem
moment auch gesagt keine keine sorge
paul du bist nicht du hast den bart
stehen lassen habe ich habe in dem
moment das so empfunden es sah so aus
als sei es tue der geisterfahrer aber
die anderen waren alle und du bist in
die richtige richtung unterwegs gewicht
wir wollen uns den dritten teil des
interviews anschauen wir haben gerade
schon gesehen dass der taliban sprecher
mudschahid eine wie er sagt herzliche
einladung an die bundeskanzlerin nach
kabul ausgesprochen hat und wir haben
ihn dann mit freundlichem gesicht
knallhart sagen hören was er unter den
gesetzen der scharia versteht und wie er
die rolle der frau dort sieht und dem
letzten teil des interviews paul hast du
mit ihm über abschiebungen auch von
deutschen straftäter nach afghanistan
gesprochen
sie haben in diesem interview viele
versicherungen abgegeben das niemanden
etwas passieren wird wie erklären sie
sich dann dass so viele menschen angst
vor den taliban haben und flüchten
die angst stammt daher dass es in den
letzten 20 jahren propaganda über uns
gegeben hat die menschen hatten den
falschen eindruck dass die taliban
menschen töten und sie nicht am leben
lassen diese fehlinformationen über uns
hatten natürlich ihre folgen deswegen
gibt es immer noch einige leute die noch
angst haben oder uns nicht trauen es gab
viele leute oder beamte in den
vergangenen regierung die zivilisten
getötet haben und diese leute fürchten
ebenfalls um ihr leben aber wir können
nur wiederholen dass diese angst
unbegründet ist wir stellen für
niemanden in diesem land eine bedrohung
dar niemand schwebt in gefahr
afghanistan ist unser gemeinsames
heimatland jeder mit verschiedenen
ansichten kann hier leben und an der
entwicklung des landes mitarbeiten wir
versichern ihnen dass ihr leben
geschützt ist und dass für sie keine
bedrohung besteht
in deutschland wird über die flüchtlinge
diskutiert ob sie in ein nachbarland
österreich geschickt werden oder
vielleicht zurück nach afghanistan
was würden sie der deutschen regierung
sagen falls sie die flüchtlinge zurück
nach afghanistan schickt
wir wollen dass alle afghanen die sich
im ausland vor allem in deutschland als
flüchtlinge aufhalten zurück in ihr
eigenes land kommen denn ich weiß dass
die deutsche regierung ihre eigenen
probleme mit den flüchtlingen hat und
die flüchtlinge wiederum haben
schwierigkeiten mit den regelungen und
verordnungen in anderen ländern dieser
afghanen werden also unter ungewissen
bedingungen leben wenn sie in andere
europäische länder gehen wir wollen dass
sie in ihre heimat zurückkehren wo sie
die regelungen und verordnungen kennen
somit können sie auch mit allen anderen
schwierigkeiten umgehen wir hoffen
afghanistan so weit und so zuverlässig
zu entwickeln das alle afghanen auf der
ganzen welt freiwillig in ihre heimat
zurückkehren
was wäre ihre botschaft an die kanzlerin
sie haben auch bereits gesagt dass sie
angela merkel in afghanistan willkommen
heißen würde
zunächst möchten wir dass unsere
regierung von allen ländern der welt und
vor allem von deutschland anerkannt wird
wir möchten dass unsere diplomatischen
beziehungen so gut wie möglich
wiederhergestellt werden wenn es gute
diplomatische beziehungen gibt dann gibt
es auch authentizität und
verlässlichkeit dafür müssen wir in
kontakt mit der deutschen regierung
stehen und wir würden kanzlerin merkel
nach afghanistan einladen gleichzeitig
möchten wir auch deutschland besuchen
wir möchten mit allen ländern der welt
diplomatische beziehungen unterhalten
und vor allem mit deutschland denn
deutschland hat gute historisch
zurückreichende beziehungen zu
afghanistan
zuvor sind die taliban selten auf fotos
oder in videos in erscheinung getreten
wie fühlt es sich an dass sie jetzt
weltweit im fernsehen gezeigt
wir haben uns aus sicherheitsgründen
nicht gezeigt wir konnten keine fotos
machen oder persönlich mit den medien
sprechen die situation erfordert es nun
dass wir im fernsehen auftreten und mit
den medien in kontakt sind ich halte das
auch für einen guten schritt denn wir
werden in einer beziehung zum rest der
welt stehen und unsere authentizität
wird deutlich werden wir sind ein teil
dieser welt und nehmen unsere rolle
ernst ich arbeite von 6 uhr morgens bis
mitternacht
was für skurrile was für seltsame sätze
und gleichzeitig so beeindruckend von
diesem taliban sprecher mudschahid der
sagt er möchte diplomatische beziehungen
mit allen ländern er sagt wir sind ein
teil dieser welt via taliban und dafür
arbeite ich von 6 uhr morgens bis
mitternacht julian
ja wir lernen die taliban haben sie
ähnliche arbeitszeiten
mehr angst hoch faszinierend was der
mann da sagt weil es zeigt wie tief sich
dieses neue taliban regime offenbar mit
der geopolitischen lage und auch mit den
schwachpunkten in der geopolitischen
lage beschäftigt das thema flüchtlinge
abgaben in deutschland das wasser da
beschrieben hat könnte ja akkurater
nicht sein viele menschen die aus
afghanistan er gekommen sind haben
tatsächlich probleme damit sich hier
einzufügen in diese gesellschaft und ja
das haben sie weil sie vielerorts so
leben wie in afghanistan und deswegen
ist das eine spannende antwort in die
antwort des taliban-sprechers stellt die
bundesregierung ja hier vor allem ganz
knallhartes dilemma noch sagt die region
nein wir wollen nicht nach afghanistan
abschieben abschiebe staubt keine
straftäter nach afghanistan abziehen
dazu zwei klare punkte erstens habe ich
eben schon gesagt nach sharia haben
straftäter die wir in deutschland als
straftäter verurteilt in afghanistan oft
gar nicht zu befürchten weil die
vergewaltigung eben in afghanistan kein
verbrechen des mannes sondern absurder
und abstruser weise ein verbrechen der
frau ist deswegen muss man hier sagen
natürlich abschieben nach afghanistan
wenn sie dort nach der stadt ihren nicht
zu befürchten haben
dass die scharia
der sprecher der taliban sagte erzählt
dort etwas was ich an dem punkt führt
tatsächlich glaubwürdig halte die
taliban wollen eine afghanistan schaffen
wie sehr viele afghanen natürlich nicht
die modernen afghanen die jetzt 20 jahre
das freiheitliche lieben ihn auf in
kabul gekostet haben aber das würde ich
sagen nach vielen jahren dich dort
verbracht habe die mehrheit der afghanen
sich wünscht die taliban wollen ein
ordnungsprinzip mit der scharia schaffen
was viele afghanen sich wünschen das
wird von vielen afghanen als ihre
kulturelle stabilität empfunden die
shakira und dann stellt sich natürlich
die frage ja gut wenn das halt das
rechtssystem vor ort ist und das was man
sich in diesem land wird warum dann
dahin nicht abschieben das ist die frage
die die bundesregierung in den nächsten
tagen beantworten muss zumal hier ja
nicht nur über abschiebungen geredet
worden ist sondern sozusagen über eine
einladung an die menschen die ihr auch
vor dem krieg den der westen dort
geführt hat geflohen sind zurückzukommen
in die heimat und die heimat aufzubauen
und warum wir jetzt menschen daran
hindern sollen diese einladung
abzulehnen das müsste die
bundesregierung dann erkennen insofern
buch interessante aussage das heißt paul
das wird hier noch mal eine ganz neue
innenpolitische debatte auslösen diese
aussagen des taliban-sprechers wie kommt
das aber diese diese offenen arme kommt
doch zu uns ihr flüchtlinge die ihr
abgehauen seit nach europa nach
deutschland wie kommt das in der
community hier in deutschland was
glaubst du kennst ja viele hier lebende
afghane also beispielsweise in der
großen community in hamburg oder ganz
genauso in berlin
ich glaube dass die menschen wissen dass
diese versprechungen am ende nichts wert
sind ich glaube dass auch der
taliban-sprecher nicht dafür stehen kann
wirklich sicherheit zu gewährleisten
und ich wage die prognose dass wir da
vielleicht ist super sprechen können und
dass politiker das fördern können
fordern können aber dass keine
abschiebung passieren werden in den
nächsten monaten und auch nicht in den
nächsten jahren davon gehe ich stark aus
denn ich glaube dass am ende dieser
abschiebung gerichtlich untersagt werden
weil durch die stadt nicht stabilität in
afghanistan eine situation entstanden
ist das keine leute gehen abgeschoben
werden dürfen und wahrscheinlich auch
nicht abgeschoben werden davon gehe ich
stark aus und wenn wir uns anschauen das
immer noch tausende leute hier in kabul
sitzen und nicht wissen wie sie
rauskommen sollen weil sie verfolgt
werden dann glaube ich sollten wir uns
erstmal auf diejenigen konzentrieren auf
die ortskräfte konzentrieren die hier
noch festsetzen denn das gehört ja auch
dazu neben der tatsache dass in diesem
flieger einzelne straftäter waren dass
wir es nicht geschafft haben die leute
herauszuholen die für uns den kopf
hingehalten haben und das ist glaube ich
momentan das noch viel größere thema
aber das ist ja eine gleichzeitig
absurde situation julian einerseits
versuchen wir gerade mit den taliban ins
gespräch zu kommen den möglicherweise
große summen zu überweisen damit wir
noch leute aus dem land gegen den willen
der taliban raus bekommen die uns war
irgendwann geholfen haben und
gleichzeitig sagte der taliban-sprecher
freunde kommt zu uns euch passiert hier
nichts das ist ja absurd
die frage ist doch wo hingeht da die
politische dynamik in deutschland
ich würde prognostizieren dass in
deutschland nicht über monate das
gespräch sein wird wie viele ortskräfte
haben wird rausgeholt sind jetzt
wirklich schon genug da haben wir jetzt
70 80 90 prozent ähnlich über der
impfquote haben wir jetzt schon wirklich
genug aus afghanistan nach deutschland
geholt das wird nicht die debatte in
deutschland seien die politische debatte
in deutschland wird sein gibt es noch
einen grund dass die menschen die als
flüchtlinge nach afghanistan zu uns
gekommen sind als kriegsflüchtlinge dass
er ein aufenthaltsrecht in deutschland
jetzt nicht endet und da ist einfach der
die frage wie stabil wird das
afghanistan der taliban es muss ja kein
afghanistan sein mit dem wir werte
politisch übereinstimmen es muss ein
afghanistan sein dass stabiles und in
dem kein krieg herrscht und ich glaube
das wird die entscheidende debatte den
nächsten wochen und monate werden ist
afghanistan so stabil dass wir nicht
mehr nur darüber sprechen straftäter
oder ob wir straftäter nach afghanistan
abschieben und zurück führt sondern all
die menschen die derzeit einen
vorläufigen aufheizzeit haben da
sprechen wir über zehntausende der wald
in afghanistan krieg herrscht wenn den
taliban
das gelingt was in ihrem eigenen
interesse ist und wofür sie von russland
china pakistan mit milliarden
unterstützt werden dann wird der
fluchtgrund wegfallen und dann werden
wir die debatte in deutschland haben ist
es jetzt nicht zeit zehntausende die als
flüchtlinge kriegsflüchtlinge zu uns
gekommen sind nach afghanistan zurück zu
führen er sagte auch immer stabilität
das war vorhin hier in der runde mit
wolfgang kubicki und
alexander dobrindt auch das
entscheidende wort und auch wolfgang
kubicki sagte na wenns stabiles dann
kann man auch wieder abschieben was
bedeutet den zusammenhang in dem
zusammenhang für euch beide stabilität
in diesem land also die abwesenheit von
krieg von
militärischer gewalt
also erstmal muss man ja vom ist-zustand
ausgehen kann ich möchte julian da
einmal hart widersprechen denn
afghanistan besteht ja nicht nur aus
kabul was wir aus den regionen drum
herum hören auch in diesen tagen ist
dass da leute erschossen werden die
gefängnisse sind voll mit politischen
gegnern ich habe gerade aus persönlichen
geschichten begegnungen berichtet dass
sozusagen leute verfolgt wurden weil sie
für us-amerikaner gearbeitet haben und
davon gibt es unzählige fälle wir wissen
dass reporter ohne grenzen gerade
darüber berichtet hat wie journalisten
festgenommen wurden die eigentlich auf
einer liste standen die nach deutschland
kommen sollten also während sozusagen
hier der horror ausbricht darüber oder
immer noch dort ist die taliban hölle
wie wir es nennen bei bild und dann
darüber zu sprechen dass jetzt leute die
in deutschland eine vorübergehende
heimat gefunden haben hier hin wieder
abgeschoben werden könnten das empfinde
ich als absurd und auch wird der rolle
deutschlands in der welt nicht gerecht
denn ich glaube dass wir hier erst mal
ein großes versagen zu verantworten
haben nicht nur dass wir die leute nicht
evakuieren konnten sondern dass wir das
überhaupt zugelassen haben dass dieses
land in der situation ist und da denke
ich sollten wir nicht zuerst über
abschiebungen sprechen sondern darüber
wie wir den menschen helfen können die
wir so im stich gelassen haben das ist
natürlich eine sicht das ist natürlich
eine sicht die extrem von den
erfahrungen vor ort geprägt ist und auf
habe ich auch volles verständnis
trotzdem würde ich sagen sobald wir
hunderte von millionen an steuern an die
taliban überweisen können sie sich auch
wieder um ihre stadt und genau die
debatte läuft nicht nur zwischen euch
beiden sondern längst auch hier in der
innenpolitik wie wir zuvor zwischen
wolfgang kubicki peter neumann und
alexander dobrindt erleben konnten wir
danken euch beiden für diese diskussion
aber vor allen dingen für die einordnung
für die analyse dieses so spannenden
interviews von dir paul mit dem taliban
sprecher mudschahid dass wir morgen früh
ja das sind nur noch ein paar stunden ab
9 uhr bei bild life weiterhin
analysieren werden ein interview das
exklusiv war und über das nicht nur
deutschland sondern die welt am morgigen
montag früh auf jeden fall spricht danke
euch beiden gute nach danke ihnen fürs
zuschauen
[Musik]